tic tac tic tac tic tac salut je suis
venu vous dire qu'il me reste 38 ans à
vivre ainsi que neuf mois c'est ce jour
47 minutes et 54 secondes 53 52
cinquante-et-une 50 ça fait flipper dans
cette vidéo on va parler du temps du
temps en général mais aussi du temps
avoué un petit peu du temps à moi là par
exemple cette monde c'est la tique
heures elle me permet de savoir dans
combien de temps je vais mourir dit
comme ça ça a l'air un petit peu
déprimant évidemment la montre est pas
voyante elle se base sur des
statistiques selon le pays dans lequel
on est l'espérance de vie moyenne pour
un homme comme moi qui ai fumé tant
d'années qui voit tant d'alcool par
semaine et caetera et caetera et elle te
sort un truc et en l'occurrence quand 8
ans et 9 mois pour moi mais c'est
amusant de se dire que dans notre
société on prête énormément de valeur à
l'âge qu'on a donc autant qu'ils aient
passé et on essaie de se dévoiler un
petit peu la face je me suis fait un col
à maya tout seul on essaye de se voiler
la face
concernant le temps qui reste à venir on
veut pas trop savoir mais c'est très
important de se dire l'instant présent
c'est le seul instant qu'ils à vivre
maintenant
d'ailleurs la seule chose dont on est
sûr hanté que le temps existe maintenant
au moment où je dis la phrase parce que
là je me souviens de l'avoir dit mais
rien ne me prouve que ce temps là à
exister à elle compliquée cette vidéo
quand même le temps réel le temps
linéaire le temps qui s'écoule il existe
après notre manière de le quantifier
elle nous appartient mais qu'on le
quantifie une paille continuera de
couler sauf en norvège il existe un
endroit la première zone de non tant au
monde c'est un sujet qui vous allez
halluciner et ça je vous en reparlerai
plus tard dans la vidéo parce que j'ai
d'autres choses avant votre temps vous
mesdames et messieurs est infinie loïc
génériques
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parle de temps mais
je veux aussi vous parler du projet le
plus personnel de ma vie j'y reviendrai
un peu plus tard dans la vidéo ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que j'ai toujours
été curieux de tout mais ça vous savez
je suis curieux de n'importe quoi et
c'est même un problème en fait parce que
j'ai envie de tout explorer et si j'ai
le malheur de rencontrer quelqu'un qui
est un peu passionné et bien moi je vais
l'écouter parler mais peu importe ce qui
fait dans la vie ici c'est sa passion et
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à
lire des livres sur à peu près tous les
sujets et puis après à me passionner un
peu pour le mentalisme l'influencent la
psychologie l'illusionnisme la mémoire
j'ai toujours eu envie de tout faire
c'est pour ça aussi que je fais un
spectacle mais j'écris des livres et
puis aussi que je fais des vidéos et
peut-être que demain je ferai autre
chose parce que j'ai pas le temps
la montre elle lundi qu elle me dit
fabien tu à 38 ans pour tout explorer et
avoir des expériences un peu partout et
découvrir des choses parce que quand tu
découvres quelque chose et un petit big
bang qui sortent dans ton cerveau n'ai
jamais eu envie d'attendre que les
choses se passent pour pouvoir vivre des
expériences c'est pour ça que j'ai envie
de tout faire c'est pour la sensation
quand je dis d'expérience et pas les
compétences ou les ce qu'il sait c'est
vraiment pour le côté ressenti de
l'expérience en fait tu fais quelque
chose tu te découvre quelque chose et
j'aime ces émotions là mais comme j'ai
toujours eu envie de tout faire de tout
lire de toutes explorées je me suis vite
retrouvé confronté à une problématique
c'est peu c'est le temps qui passe
justement le temps qu'ils étaient pas
vraiment si flexible associer un
deuxième problème ce problème c'est le
plus gros procrastinateurs que cette
terre n'est jamais porté il va arriver
dans quelques secondes
voilà c'est moi sans aucune surprise
c'est moi je j'ai toujours eu ce vrai
problème vous avait déjà parlé en vidéo
que je remets tout au lendemain je suis
pas très bon à tout ça en fait à me
motiver à me mettre en place un organisé
je l'ait jamais été et je sais que vous
dites manière mais là c'est pas possible
c'est trop bizarre le mec il a fait une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
il continue les vidéos et écrit des
bouquins il fait plein de choses tout le
temps oui alors attention dessus
procrastinateurs abstinente est à dire
que à cause du fait que j'étais comme ça
j'ai dû trouver des solutions et
comprendre un peu qui j'étais comprendre
un peu ce qu'était le temps et
comprendre ce que c'était les émotions
qui fait qu'on reporte bret comment on
fait les choses sans souffrance pour
pouvoir les faire c'est comme ça que
j'en suis arrivée là parce que à la base
je ne suis pas du tout bon mais pas du
tout pas du tout dans l'organisation
mais pas du tout gea s'est dit pas du
tout
le résultat quand il est comme moi trop
gros procrastinateurs sais que tu coures
tout le temps tu es toujours à la bourre
tu rends toujours tous les projets ou ce
que tu dois randoux ce que tu dois faire
mais c'est toujours dans un stress
permanent associé à une charge mentale
énorme puisqu'on est toujours en train
de penser aux choses qu'on doit faire et
qu'on aurait déjà dû faire j'ai analysé
ma vie au fur et à mesure et je me suis
dit ok comment on peut transformer ça et
comment je peux m'aider à bouger ça
c'est comme ça en fait que j'ai commencé
à observer ma vie et à voir ce que je
pouvais en retirer un autre exemple de
ma vie où je me suis rendu compte que sa
charge et mentalement et ça fait perdre
du temps et le jour où on m'a proposé un
super job d'été pour être directeur d'un
centre de loisirs mais aussi de
plusieurs centres de loisirs même temps
sauf que je venais juste de monter ma
société est en fait je vous avais des
deux trucs dans l'image savais pas trop
quoi en faire et d'un côté il y avait la
stabilité et quelque chose dans le temps
qui était quasiment un plan de carrière
mais de l'autre côté il y avait une
espèce de liberté un projet qui motivés
qui avait peut-être de l'avenir ou pas
ou en tout cas j'avais quand même
travaillé un an pour monter pour monter
ça c'est en 2006 j'ai passé des jours et
des jours et des jours dessus j'ai
demandé l'avis de tout le monde et c'est
là où je me suis rendu compte que leur
avis ne comptait pas elle leur avis il
était soumis à leur propre grille de
lecture qu'est ce qu'ils auraient fait
eux pas ma place selon leur valeur à eux
selon ce qu'il ya dans leur inconscient
selon leur expérience de vie j'ai monté
tout un système du coup de prises de
décisions hyper rapide nécessite juste
une feuille un crayon pour y voir plus
clair et même une autre méthode de prise
de décision qui est instantané et dont
vous serez certain que la réponse est la
meilleure réponse pour vous ça ce sont
les [ __ ] laissa les mantras moi j'ai
démontré que son autonomie et liberté
je vous en parlerai un peu plus
longuement mais c'est en ayant vécu
cette situation là à l'époque que
j'étais obligé trouver une solution pour
prendre la décision être sûr que c'était
où la bonne ou la moins mauvaise je me
suis mais c'est pas possible de prendre
autant de temps pour ça que cette
fatigue autant mentalement avec cette
charge tant que ça devrait être beaucoup
plus rapide que ça allait un dernier
exemple concret pour la route je
travaillais dans un restaurant donc à la
rochelle un toujours c'était dans les
années 2000 début 2000
parce que oui il est extrêmement vieux
et en bon procrastinateurs que j'étais
j'ai essayé de ne pas prendre de pause
ou la plus tard possible parce que les
autres faisait ça et les autres qui
bossait alors je me disais je paie sage
pour ma pause plus tard et tout parce
que sinon
je vais pas me rend maître etc je me
connais nanane agen procrastinateurs est
tout sauf que j'ai observé les autres et
je me suis aperçu que tout ce qui
faisait comme moi qui prenaient leur
pose le plus tard possible
au lieu de la prendre quand il en avait
besoin et bien la demi-heure voire même
leur avance à la pause qui précédait
alors que quand il repousse
elle est allaité deux trois quatre fois
moins productives productif dans le sens
si vous était inefficace il allait moins
vite
il prenait plus de plaisir dans leur
travail ils s'épuisent et tellement que
la pause n'allait pas réussir à
compenser l'épuisement qu'ils avaient eu
à essayer de la repousser vous voyez un
petit peu il vient tous ces éléments là
c'est vraiment les péripéties que j'ai
vécu que j'ai subi même et bien à chaque
fois je me disais est ce qu'on peut en
retirer quelque chose est ce qu'on peut
en tirer une conclusion qu'on pourrait
globalisé dans notre vie pour essayer de
moins subir c'est pas de s'améliorer le
but c'est pas d'être hyper productif où
il perd organisé mais est-ce qu'on peut
ne pas souffrir est-ce qu'on peut ne pas
avoir de charge mentale la première
solution que j'ai trouvée que j'ai mise
en place alors c'était pour moi
évidemment c'est le système d métrage
appeler ça comme ça mais c'est ma
méthode n'existait pas les miens son
autonomie et liberté mais ils viennent
pas de n'importe hong un processus
complet pour les trouvais que je vais
pas vous résumer maintenant parce que ça
me permet de vous présenter quelque
chose de très personnel
votre temps est infini alors attention
ça n'a rien à voir avec un livre
d'astuces c'est beau c'est une
méthodologie mais c'est ce qu'on appelle
un essai c'est à dire que il ya de quoi
lire ça m'a pris un an pour écrire ça et
qu'est-ce que j'ai mis dedans mais j'ai
mis ma vie personnelle vraiment terre ce
que ce que je vous raconte là les petits
extraits dit ils sont évidemment plus
long dans le livre et à chaque fois ça
donne la situation est l'élément que ça
m'a fait comprendre et comment je les
globalisé en fait dans ma vie et donc il
ya les mantras en fait pourquoi
autonomie et liberté comment j'ai trouvé
ça commence à ma décharge est
complètement mentalement comment ça m'a
permis de prendre les décisions
rapidement 2 - procrastiner de mime
organisé avec quelque chose de si bête
que ça parce qu'il faut comprendre un
truc c'est que vous êtes les gagnants
d'un grand jeu en fait imaginer que
chaque jour vous vous réveillez vous
gagnez 1440 euros c'est énorme
dites vous que c'est vrai tous les
matins vous réveillez vous vous avez
1440 euros qui tente comme s'est
instantanément mais il ya des règles les
deux règles ses versements peuvent
s'arrêter à tout moment vous savez pas
quand vous savez pas prévenu ça pète
demain ça peut être dans une
ou ne savais pas qu'en hockey la
deuxième règle c'est que ces 1440 euros
ne peuvent pas être économisés ils
doivent être dépensés chaque jour
imaginez ce que vous feriez si vraiment
c'était vrai si vraiment je vous annonce
que vous avez gagné 1440 euros et que ça
peut s'arrêter n'importe quand mais que
ça doit être dépensée chaque jour qu'est
ce que vous feriez avec ça je suis sûr
que rien qu'en disant ça vous avez déjà
des projets des choses que vous aimeriez
faire etc
tu vois dans la réalité vous êtes
gagnant avec les mêmes règles de mille
quatre cent quarante minutes par jour
c'est un pactole considérable ben en
fait on le gâche on le gâche soit à
reporter les choses quand on est
procrastinateurs comme moi je le suis
attention obstinant maintenant soit on
essaie de faire dix mille choses mais un
peu mal est en fait du coup on est
toujours surchargé mentalement et on
court toujours après le temps etc 1444
minutes on les voit pas passer ce qui
est pas beaucoup mieux mais vous voyez
cet exemple en fait avec un gain du loto
c'est à ça ramène un peu au truc de
départ c'est-à-dire le nombre d'années
qui me reste à vivre en fait la montre
les 10 38 ans mais en fait j'en sais
rien je trouverais 50 ans à vivre mais
ça se trouve il me reste aussi deux
jours je n'en sais rien et je m'en fous
ce qui est important c'est du coup de
faire les choses qui me plaisent
vraiment dans le quotidien d'explorer
tout ce que j'ai envie d'explorer et
pour tous à se donner les moyens de le
faire et le meilleur moyen c'est d'avoir
une espèce jaillir de méthode mais c'est
presque ce que je vous ai mis dans le
livre c'est presque une philosophie en
fait de vie parce que je n'y pense plus
ça se fait tout seul et je savais par
rapport à mon défaut que pour que ça
fonctionne il fallait que ça ne me fasse
jamais souffrir
donc tout ce que j'ai mis en place et
des choses je me force pas à faire en
fait que je me force pas à respecter
sinon le sait ou ne respecterai je vous
explique un peu comment j'ai organisé ma
pensée là dedans la première partie le
premier tiers du livre c'est sûr changer
fondamentalement votre vision du temps
qu'est ce que le temps qu'est ce que
vaut votre temps combien vaut votre
temps comment décidé sans perdre de
temps comment respecter son temps
comment avoir l'esprit du temps il ya
même un rapide voyage dans le futur
la deuxième partie le deuxième tiers
sait comment organiser votre temps selon
vos vrais désirs
donc il ya les puissants de base de
l'organisation les puissants booster des
performances les puissantes technique
pour gagner du temps au quotidien
le puissant remède contre la surcharge
dont je vous parlais et la dernière
partie de deuxième tiers c'est gagner du
temps chaque jour donc les astuces pour
soi l'enfer c'est les autres
comment on gère ce qui est externe à
nous-mêmes après et ça va encore regardé
astuces encore plus concrète et
immédiate et ça termine après avec votre
temps est un pilier des derniers secrets
c'est des choses que j'ai pas réussi à
classer des théories que j'ai que
j'utilise en fait dans mon travail c'est
ça qui fait qu'à un moment donné si on
regarde bien en deux ans de ma vie j'ai
fais pas ça en représentation dont une
autoproduction à l'olympia route en
faisant environ 700 vidéos et en
écrivant de livres une méthode de
mémoire la memory box est un jeu menteur
menteur et en faisant encore d'autres
choses à côté mais c'est pas que j'ai
plus de temps que vous de base les mêmes
mille quatre cent quarante minutes le
matin mais je me suis aperçu que le
temps était flexible on pouvait le
manipuler on pouvait le tordre un petit
peu et on voit les choses différemment
au final et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
mettre là-dedans pour vous partager ça
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est très
personnel parce que dans les essais en
temps normal on donne des astuces on
parle de théories etc
mais à chaque fois je pars de ma vie
personnelle je me livre énormément dans
ce livre vous emmène un peu comme s'il y
avait une caméra avec moi dans mon passé
dans mes souvenirs et je vous fais voir
ça déjà pour assumer tous les défauts
que j'ai pigé pu être ce qui s'est passé
dans ma vie mais que vous puissiez
vraiment comprendre que quand je dis
voilà pourquoi je fais ci comme ça comme
ça et voilà pourquoi ça fonctionne que
vous puissiez voir le point de départ
qu'il faut comprendre avec le temps
c'est qu'il n'existe pas vraiment nous
ce qu'on appelle le temps c'est toujours
quantifier des heures des jours des
semaines des mois n'a aucun intérêt et
c'est pour ça que tout début de la vidéo
je vous parlais de lille
deux sauts marois en norvège c'est là le
lieu de non temps dont je vous parlais
si neil assez particulière leur histoire
elle est dingue sur cette île qui situe
au nord de la norvège il ya 350
habitants c'est un petit peu au dessus
du cercle polaire comme ils sont au
dessus du cercle polaire il en 69 jours
où le soleil ne se couche pas et ils ont
quasiment 50 jours où il fait demi en
permanence donc ils n'ont pas le même
rapport au temps que nous ils ont donc
aboli la notion de temps tels que nous
on la définit
parce que eux ils peuvent tondre leur
pelouse à 4 heures du matin ils ont une
flexibilité surtout tu peux aller un peu
à l'école quand tu veux etc
ils considèrent au point de vue plus
globale mondiale il pense que les gens
qui déprime sont en majorité déprimé à
cause de la notion de temps qui passe et
la notion de temps quantifier et eux en
abolissant le temps chez eux en créant
le premier lieu dans le monde quand même
la première zone de non tant ils ont
rendu tout ça très flexible donc le
temps s'écoule le temps passe c'est
normal mais ils ont viré toute la charge
émotionnelle qui était lié à ça et le
stress du temps qui passe et les codes à
respecter les horaires etc etc et ils
ont changé complètement leur mindset et
c'est très très stimulant c'est la
dernière chose que j'ai découverte sur
le temps j'en parle également dans le
lit parce que euh c'est le changement de
philosophie qui va vraiment au delà de
tout ce que moi j'ai pu explorer
forcément dans une vie qui est quand
même réagir par derek de société un jour
j'irai explorer cette île plutôt visité
que explorer parce que c'est pas parce
que j'y suis pas allé qu'elle n'existe
pas donc ctc s'appelle votre temps est
infinie c'est un petit clin d'oeil à
ceux qui ont lu mes livres précédents
votre cerveau est extraordinaire et
votre cerveau est définitivement
extraordinaire vous savez qu'à l'époque
j'avais mis définitivement dans le titre
pour qu'on comprenne que cette série-là
des deux livres d'astuces à l'été avec
déterminé que je voulais faire quelque
chose de plus ancrée de plus profond et
en vérité c'est ça le premier livre que
je voulais écrire mais à l'époque je me
sentais pas légitime
josy mais les gens ils vont se dire mais
qu'est ce qu'il y connaît maintenant
j'ai prouvé que je savais rendre le
temps flexible et un fini par rapport à
tout ce que j'ai pu faire lors des temps
à chaque fois très très courant tout en
ayant encore du temps pour moi c'est ça
qui est intéressant parce que le but ce
n'est pas d'être ultra productifs qui
fait tout dans tous les sens le but
c'est d'arriver à faire ce qu'on veut
qu'on le souhaite et pour ça il ya nous
manque la thur du temps il ya du temps
de travail a du temps personnel il ya du
temps pour soi il ya du temps avec les
autres et on n'a pas tous les mêmes
envies mais par contre on doit pouvoir
prendre tous les temps qu'on veut et
c'est possible le livre sort demain dans
toutes les librairies vous pourrez le
retrouver et évidemment sur internet
mais je vous recommande vivement d'aller
dans les librairies
vous allez pouvoir découvrir aussi
d'autres ouvrages avoir des conseils des
libraires
c'est leur métier n'hésitez pas à aller
les voir c'est important de soutenir le
métier de libraire et vous avez un lien
dans la description ça vous emmène sur
mon site où vous avez les biens pour le
commander en ligne pour ceux qui veulent
absolument le commander en ligne la
version numérique sort en même temps le
livre sort en belgique en même temps qu
en france au québec
un mois après parce que le temps que le
livre nage ou en suisse est quasiment en
même temps qu'en france et j'en aurai
quelques-uns à la fin de chacun de mes
spectacles vous savez qu'à la fin de
chacun des spectacles quelle que soit la
date je suis là en signature pour les
photos etc
et bien il y aura aussi quelques livres
avec moi et vous vous dites mais viendra
tue un petit peu partout en dédicace il
y en aura pour l'instant il y en a deux
qui sont annoncés c'est celle de la fnac
des ternes à paris ce sera le 23 octobre
et le 24 novembre je serai au salon du
livre de colmar pour toutes les autres
dates de dédicaces dans les librairies
les culturales et fnac les salons du
livre
je mets les infos comme d'habitude sur
mon site internet il ya des dates de
spectacles et les dates de conférences
quand il y en a et les dates de
dédicaces et aussi sur instagram jeu
l'annoncent toujours c'est instagram
là il faut me suivre et plutôt que de me
demander en commentaire alors que je
mets toutes les infos alors voilà
forcément ce livre c'est un peu plus un
pavé que les autres il est il est
beaucoup plus long il est beaucoup plus
dense mais il est surtout beaucoup plus
personnel je voulais l'écrire depuis le
départ je faisais pas le faire je me
sentais pas légitime à le faire je suis
dit ça va intéresser est ce que je suis
capable aussi de l'écrire je me pose
vraiment la question tu vas écrire des
astuces je me disais ok ça c'est bon
mais est ce que je suis capable d'écrire
un vrai livre comme ça un vrai et c et
c'est parce que vous avez été là pour
les deux livres précédents et que vos
retours n'ont porté que je me suis ok
j'essaie de l'écrire cette année
d'habitude je te remets les livres au
mois de mai là il m'a fallu beaucoup
plus de temps pour l'écrire pour être à
peu près satisfait pour tailler le truc
et c'est toujours en pensant à vous je
les fais en me disant et en même temps
ça va les aider en fait donc il faut
absolument essayer d'aller au bout de
cette démarche la fille très content du
résultat
j'ai fait ça en pensant à vous et pour
vous donc j'espère vraiment
qui vous plaira donc dites moi quand
vous l'aurez lu ce que vous en avez
pensé vous avez tous les liens dans la
description je suis très ému de cette
sortie la plus que n'importe quel autre
chose que j'ai fait c'est très très
important pour moi d'avoir écrit ce
livre
donc voilà maintenant j'ai les pétoches
pour demain parce que c'est la sortie et
vous allez la voir dans vos mains et je
me dis waouh j'ai tout mis là dedans et
maintenant ça va être dans vos mavs
merci beaucoup pour tout ça parce que
sans vous je l'aurais pas fait à très
bientôt de chat